having your picture taken is part of the
job of being the president
sometimes photographers capture the
tensest moments of the office or some of
the lighter side of the presidency but
now we're getting a look at what's
believed to be the oldest surviving
photograph of an American president this
early daguerreotype of the sixth
President John Quincy Adams was taken in
March of 1843 about fourteen years after
he left the White House according to an
entry in Adams journal quote the
operation is performed in half a minute
but is yet altogether incomprehensible
to me fascinated by the process
Adams gifted the photo to his friend
Horace Everett a congressman from
Vermont the five by four inch picture
was found by one of Everett's
descendants in the 90s and now it's
headed for auction at Sotheby's the
importance of this photograph is that it
is a rare early American portrait it's a
historical object as well Adams who was
notoriously picky about how he looked in
portraits and photos seemed to like this
one enough to give it as a gift to have
the ability to see who he was in a
photograph is really special he is not
just an idea here he is the man himself
the auction is in October in the
estimate is may go for up to $250,000 it
looks a little grumpy in that photograph
I thought yeah I'm actually just amazed
that it's survived over time you think
of those photos have disappeared that
itself is extraordinary yeah